l'une des plus anciennes sinon la plus
ancienne entreprise horlogère de
besançon a été créé en 1876 c'est la
fabrique d'horlogerie tribe qui à
l'époque a obtenu le premier prix de
l'observatoire en 1985 l'entreprise qui
avait alors 111 ans était à boussu
racheté par une nouvelle équipe elle
prenait un nouveau départ sur un marché
difficile où la concurrence pollue
d'extrême orient et particulièrement
virulent de nos comme objectif déjà au
départ de faire 30 % d'exportation chose
que la société ne faisait pas avant
et d'augmenter notre chiffre d'affaires
sur le plan national et vous y êtes
parvenu sur le plan national on y est
parvenu sur le plan exportations
n'arrive à 20 25 % actuellement mais
cette année on va certainement y arriver
ce succès qui se dessine est la suite
logique du choix qui a été fait
l'entreprise travaille en effet sur deux
créneaux dame offre publicitaire dont le
développement de cesse de s'affirmer et
d'amandes dit fantaisie qui permet à
l'imagination de s'exprimer et au
créateur de free à la clientèle une
gamme très étendue de montres originales
mais comme pour la mode c'est un
perpétuel renouvellement
faut changer à papa tous les six mois
pour trouver des choses de nouveau tous
les six mois autrement ce fait copier
surtout par nos confrères disons nos
confrères d'extrême orient qui arrive
très vite et qui copie très très vite
alors comment vous situez-vous justement
par rapport à hong kong tous ces pays là
est-ce que c'est pas trop difficile de
lutter contre une part et concurrence
non parce qu on a quand même la création
française on essaie de trouver des
choses qu'une fois pas les autres depuis
trois ans les montres tribe ont vu leur
personnel triplé il est passé de 18 à 54
personnes dont 26 travaillant à domicile
une telle progression de l'emploi
montrent s'il en était besoin qu'il est
toujours possible d'aller de l'avant
même dans les secteurs les plus
traditionnels à condition bien sûr de
sortir des sentiers battus